Transcription: Manon Armenoult
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
L’autre jour, je demandais
à un ami entrepreneur
comment est-ce qu’il vivait
les critiques, la pression permanente,
et cette nécessité de paraître,
tout le temps, sous son meilleur jour.
Et il m’a répondu :
« Oh, tu sais,
moi les autres, je m’en fous.
Je suis quelqu’un de détaché. »
En rentrant chez moi,
je me suis demandé ce que moi j’étais.
Et je me suis souvenu.
Je me suis souvenu
de tous ces messages lâchés en vue
et qui instantanément
me donnaient l’impression
d’une chute libre.
Je me suis souvenu
de toutes ces discussions
que j’ai fait et refait
le soir tard dans mon lit.
Et je me suis souvenu de cette sensibilité
que j’avais en moi depuis toujours.
Quand je suis rentré chez moi
et que j’ai creusé encore un peu,
je me suis rendu compte
que je n’étais pas du tout détaché.
Et je me suis même rendu compte
de ce que j’étais :
quelqu’un de profondément taché.
Je m’appelle Martin,
je suis entrepreneur, aventurier,
chef de communauté, créateur de contenu,
mais surtout, plus que tout,
je suis taché.
Pour utiliser un mot
que vous connaissez peut-être mieux,
je suis hypersensible.
Et je vais vous parler de ça,
de mes taches, de l’hypersensibilité.
Je vais vous en parler
avec mes mots, avec mes ressentis,
sans aucune donnée scientifique,
sans aucun diagnostic.
Je vais vous en parler
comme je le ressens.
Et peut-être que ça vous parlera
à vous aussi
parce que je crois que la sensibilité,
cela nous concerne tous.
Ce n’est pas histoire de l’avoir ou pas,
c’est ni blanc ni noir.
La sensibilité, c’est des moments,
des personnes, des situations.
Alors peut-être que ce soir,
vous vous sentirez concernés.
Mais alors, comment suis-je arrivé
à faire ce constat,
que j’étais taché ou hypersensible ?
Eh bien,
tout a commencé dans l’un des laboratoires
de recherche humain
qui me semble être le plus intéressant :
l’école.
J’ai toujours vu l’école
comme une sorte de jungle,
voire de prison parfois,
de prédateurs qui se regardent,
qui se jugent et qui parfois s’abattent.
Et au jeu des prédateurs qui s’abattent,
assurément, je n’étais qu’une proie.
Cela n’a pas duré que dans l’enfance,
mais bien au-delà.
À l’âge de 21 ans, j’ai eu dans mon école,
une réunion inter-campus.
On était 500 élèves de ma promotion
et on se retrouvait tous dans un amphi
qui était à peu près de cette taille-là
et il fallait passer à l’oral,
groupe par groupe et présenter son projet.
Et quand j’entendais les groupes passer,
je voyais autour de moi
des gens qui regardaient,
pas forcément bien, qui critiquaient,
qui jugeaient, qui se moquaient
et groupe par groupe,
la pression en moi montait.
Et au moment où mon tour vint,
j’ai fait ce que les proies font,
du moins ce que les proies
savent faire de mieux :
j’ai fui.
J’ai descendu les marches,
j’ai couru vers la porte,
je suis monté dans le premier bus,
et j’ai fui.
J’ai dit à mes camarades,
à mes professeurs
et même à mes parents,
qui sont là ce soir,
que j’avais eu un mal de ventre,
que j’avais été malade.
Peut-être que j’étais malade,
mais assurément, croyez-moi,
ça ne se passait pas dans le ventre.
Et ainsi, comme ça,
pendant de longues années,
je ne me suis pas forcément aimé
dans mon entièreté.
J’ai souvent fui
pour ne pas avoir à assumer.
J’ai parfois menti
pour ne pas avoir à me regarder.
J’ai déjà nié, pour ne pas avoir
à confronter ou à m’affronter.
En fait, j’ai passé de longues années
avec des taches
qui s’accumulaient sur mon visage,
des taches qui souvent me brûlaient.
Si on s’intéresse un peu plus
à ce que signifie être hypersensible,
du moins pour moi,
l’hypersensibilité,
c’est ressentir tout très fort.
J’ai toujours tout ressenti très fort.
Les bons moments, la vie,
les passions, les amours.
Mais aussi forcément,
les moins bons moments.
La tristesse.
La solitude.
La mort.
J’ai toujours ressenti les conflits
comme des coups de poignard,
les bons moments comme des extases
ou des orgasmes.
Et j’ai toujours vu ma tête en permanence
aller à 1000 à l’heure.
Lomepal dit dans une de ses musiques :
« Je mérite un Oscar pour tous les films
que je me suis fait. »
Mais, croyez-moi, dans ma tête,
c’est le Festival de Cannes.
On a de tout, des films d’aventures,
des films d’action,
des films d’amour, des films de genre,
des petites comédies françaises pas ouf.
Dans ma tête, il se passe des choses
que j’imagine, qui n’existent pas vraiment
et qui s’enchaînent,
qui vont toutes très très vite.
Et comme vous vous en doutez,
c’est fatigant d’avoir en permanence
des films dans sa tête.
Je vois vraiment mon esprit
comme des montagnes russes,
des hauts et des bas en permanence.
Ça demande beaucoup d’énergie,
c’est de l’investissement émotionnel.
Et si on veut aller encore plus loin
- et on va le faire -,
on peut définir mon hypersensibilité
comme sur un scope assez précis.
Ce scope- là, c’est celui
qui concerne les autres.
Je suis hypersensible des autres.
Depuis toujours, j’ai senti
et ressenti très fort les gens.
Mes relations ne sont pas
juste des échanges ou des discussions,
mais elles sont des taches
qui s’accumulent sur mon torse
et qui parfois, c’est vrai,
m’alourdissent.
Je pourrais vous expliquer
pendant des heures
toutes les pensées, les inquiétudes,
les projections que j’ai pour l’autre
- surtout pour mes proches -
qui m'habitent vraiment au quotidien.
Je refais des discussions.
Je peux refaire des relations entières
pendant des nuits, des semaines, des mois.
Mais en fait, à force de me chercher,
à force de me questionner,
à force de me demander,
j’en suis venu à cette question :
« Comment vivre
avec toutes ces taches ? »
Orelsan dit dans l’une de ses musiques :
« On dit “Sois fort
pour devenir un homme”.
Mais rappelle moi que moi,
ma force, c’est d’être sensible. »
Et moi j’ai mis presque 26 ans
à comprendre ça,
à comprendre ce que j’étais vraiment.
Juste un homme profondément
humain et sensible.
Une sorte de boule d’énergie
constamment percutée par les sentiments.
Un soleil rayonnant,
très fragile aux turbulences.
Une sorte d’éponge d’amour
dédiée à l’autre.
En fait, juste une bonne personne
au cœur débordant.
Et petit à petit, récemment,
je me suis mis à comprendre
que ce qui apparaissait
comme étant ma plus grande faiblesse,
serait peut être un jour ma force.
Alors avec la boulangère, rien n’a changé,
dès qu’elle fait la gueule,
j’ai l’impression
que c’est la fin de ma life.
Je me suis mis à comprendre
que ces sentiments,
cette sensibilité aux autres,
aux situations
ça pouvait être un super pouvoir.
Je me suis rendu compte que j’avais accès
à une sorte de vie parallèle.
Une vie parallèle où je pouvais acquérir
l’une des compétences
les plus riches à mes yeux
que quelqu’un puisse avoir,
celle de faire du bien autour de soi.
Je m’étais déjà souvent rendu compte
que j’attirais tout particulièrement
la sympathie, la bienveillance
et la gentillesse des gens.
Même de ceux qui n’avaient pas
la réputation d’avoir ça en eux.
Beaucoup me disent
que j’ai une tête de nounours,
que j’ai une tête sympa
ou des yeux gentils.
Mais je sais la vérité,
c’est ni dans mes yeux, ni sur ma tête,
c’est au fond de moi :
je pense que je respire l’humain.
Parfois dans le regard
des gens en face de moi,
je voyais, en me gigotant,
mes taches briller.
Et petit à petit,
je me suis mis à comprendre.
Je me suis mis à comprendre
que j’avais ça en moi
et j’ai décidé petit à petit
de l’utiliser.
Je me suis surpris à redonner de la force
à celui qui n’en avait plus,
à redonner de la confiance
à celui qui avait été trahi,
et même à redonner de l’espoir
à celui qui n’y croyait plus.
Petit à petit, ces taches
que j’avais tant fuies et cachées,
devenaient de petites fiertés.
Depuis que j’ai 18 ans,
j’ai créé trois entreprises :
une dans la photographie,
une dans le recrutement
et une dans le networking d’entrepreneurs.
Et en fait, toutes ces entreprises
ont un point commun qui est très clair,
c’est qu’elles ont été portées
par des communautés.
Ces communautés,
c’est moi qui les ai créées.
Et je les ai créées
non pas en le planifiant.
Je n’ai pas lu de livres,
je n’ai pas de stratégies.
J’ai créé des communautés
parce que c’est ma personnalité.
J’ai appris à parler aux gens,
à les comprendre,
mais pas en mode fake,
parce que je suis comme ça.
Puis, cette compétence qui semblait n’être
qu’une particularité humaine
s’est mise à devenir
un vrai atout dans ma vie,
mais aussi dans le business,
dans mes métiers.
Mais c’est sûrement un champ de compétence
que vous connaissez bien,
qu'on appelle la communication
ou le marketing.
Le fait de savoir ce que quelqu’un veut,
de pouvoir lui expliquer
et de savoir lui expliquer,
pourquoi on est la bonne personne
pour lui donner.
Attention, je pense que vous commencez
un peu à me cerner.
J'aurais énormément de mal à avoir
l'impression de léser n'importe qui.
Je n’ai aucunement l’intention de vendre
n’importe quoi à n’importe qui,
mais en revanche, je me suis mis
à me rendre compte avec le temps
que cette capacité à rassembler,
à réunir, à convaincre,
à me connecter avec l’intérieur des gens,
allait peut être me permettre
de réaliser mon rêve
- le vôtre aussi peut-être -,
celui d’avoir de l’impact,
celui de changer des vies,
peut-être même
de changer le monde, qui sait.
Peut-être que vous partagez
certains de ces maux avec moi,
et je sais que ce n’est pas facile,
mais il va falloir vivre avec.
Le meilleur moyen est de trouver
des petites techniques,
et j’avais envie
de vous en partager quelques unes.
Ce sont mes conseils de taché.
Le premier est très facile à donner,
c’est de relativiser.
Relativiser parce que je suis persuadé
qu’on est juste des chimpanzés
qui avons appris à construire,
à sociabiliser, à échanger.
Des chimpanzés super-développés
qui avons créé des systèmes
et des sociétés hyper complexes,
qui dépassent sûrement
le champ de compréhension
de notre propre cerveau de primate.
Et que parfois,
ça fait du bien de s’isoler,
de fermer les yeux, de prendre le temps
et de tout déconstruire,
de se rappeler
ce qui compte vraiment :
les bons moments, les gens qu’on aime,
nos passions, la vie.
À titre personnel, ça m’a beaucoup aidé
de pouvoir casser tous ces trucs complexes
qui me foutait un peu la tête en l’air
et à revenir à des basiques.
Faites le test.
Imaginez ces macaques
qui vous impressionnent au quotidien.
Imaginez-les sous un baobab
en train de faire leurs besoins.
Ils font moins les malins !
Ça fait sourire
et je pense que ça fait du bien.
Mon deuxième conseil,
il commence aussi les yeux fermés.
L’idée, ça va être de créer
un point d’ancrage positif.
dans lequel vous allez vous sentir bien.
Alors moi, c’est une hypnothérapeute
qui me l’a donné pour gérer mon stress.
Et l’idée, c’est de mettre sa main là
pour revenir à chaque fois
au même endroit,
de fermer les yeux et de se créer une zone
dans laquelle on se sent bien.
Petit à petit, vous allez créer
cette zone qui est à vous,
dont vous seul avez l'accès.
Vous voulez que je vous présente ma zone ?
Je vais vous la présenter quand même.
Moi, je suis un gladiateur.
Je suis un gladiateur dans une arène
perchée sur les nuages,
et il y a une foule dans les gradins
qui est pleine de gens
au regard bienveillant.
Et au moment où je suis face
à la cage aux lions
et où la grille s’ouvre,
un immense nounours en peluche
se met face à moi.
Ça, c'est à moi.
C’est mon moment,
c’est moi qui l’ai créé.
Créez votre moment.
Il vous permettra
de vous sentir fort et confiant.
On ferme les yeux, on y retourne.
C'est à nous.
Et on repart.
Mon dernier conseil,
il est hyper facile à donner,
beaucoup plus compliqué à appliquer,
j’en suis conscient.
C’est de communiquer.
Pas communiquer juste pour communiquer,
mais pour savoir.
Parce que si l’hypersensibilité
m’a bien appris une chose,
c’est que si on ne dialogue pas
pour obtenir des réponses concrètes,
on va se mettre à imaginer
des réponses imaginaires
qui deviendront par la suite
des vérités absolues.
Je passe ma vie
à mettre dans la tête des gens,
des avis, des points de vue,
des critiques qu’ils ne m’ont jamais dit.
Demandez-leur pour connaître la vérité,
pas celle que vous avez imaginée.
C’était la slide « Communiquer ».
Je n’ai pas totalement réussi à le faire,
mais je sens que ça fait vraiment du bien.
Enfin, pour terminer,
je vous recommanderais
- même si à nouveau c’est facile à dire -,
d’être fier de vos différences
et de les cultiver.
Je pense que ce sont celles-ci
qui vous permettront
de faire la différence
et de vous sentir exister.
Tâchez donc, s’il vous plaît,
d’arborer avec beaucoup de fierté
ces taches que vous avez
trop longtemps cachées.
Aujourd'hui, je n'ai pas fui.
C’est sûrement grâce
à vos regards bienveillants.
Peut être, avez-vous vu
briller mes tâches.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)